here are two guys who have made the leap
from Saturday Night Live to Monday Night
Live here at the Oscars please welcome
the very funny David Spade and Chris
Farley
[Music]
haha I can't believe it I just can't
believe it we're actually here at their
Academy Awards Yeah right the Academy
Awards the Primeau event of the year
seen by over a billion people and over
100 countries around the globe wow
that's more than the Frog Network on a
good Wednesday right thank you I see
Dave I see a lot of confused people out
there we don't belong here maybe there
was some sort of mix-up and right now
Jeremy Irons is performing at the improv
and Daniel day-lewis is at a fat camp in
Hilton Head oh my god oh my god well
while we're here let's announce the
nominations for a live action short film
read the nominations check
day tripas Corazon Antonio Eritrea dear
diary
David Franco and Barry Johnson Ernst and
Lycett Kim Magnuson and Anders Thomas
Jensen s Pasado's Juan Carlos
Fresnadillo
[Music]
wordless Bernadette Carranza and
Antonello daily oh all right okay and
the Oscar goes to
dear diary David Franco Barry Johnson
come on now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to thank the Academy for
recognizing that TV networks do produce
innovative work they just don't show to
you I'd like to thank the dazzling Bebe
Neuwirth and the cast and crew of dear
diary like to thank the three wise men
of the DreamWorks and their apostles who
had no doubt that we were making a
special film I'd like to thank the
executives at ABC who had just enough
doubt that we're here tonight and I'd
like to thank my hero max my mentor
Norman my ambassador Nancy my muse
Jennifer and my partners in crime Spanky
and Meg and I'd like to let them know
that I love them but there will always
be grist for the mill Jeffrey Katzenberg
Steven Spielberg and David Geffen and
everyone at dream or expect news
all right congratulations
we're still here okay now the moment the
rest of you have been waiting for
nominations for Best Picture
give it up Dave the next award is for
animated short film Chris stop toying
with my emotions
David's better this way Dave by the way
we got a telegram backstage from David
Cassidy he'd like his hairstyle back
just saw the monitor I'll take that one
all right well let's read the
nominations canhead timothy Hittle and
Chris Peterson la sala richard condi
Qwest Tyrone Montgomery and Thomas tell
ma what's pig Peter Lord
all right in the Oscar go let me help
you with that here they forgot they
forgot the other goods do Quest Tyrone
Montgomery and Thomas Delma
[Music]
oh gee what do you say in such a moment
at least our lonely puppet has two
friends now I like actually wanted to
just say one thing I'm very very happy
that Billy Crystal is doing this night
he was always my very favorite show host
of the Oscars and I'm very honored and
very happy that he's doing this thank
you okay I will try to read it from the
paper and very nervous story when making
crest we expected it to be a good film
but we were not prepared for its
tremendous success sorry now we are very
proud of it we would like to thank the
Academy our professor Paul reason for
support and all our friends for the help
and I've also my parents are here thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]